il ya un constat mais l'eau s'est
répandue comme ça oui mais après quatre
heures de chasse et delphine j'ai touché
parce que prévu c'est isabelle après les
pro chasse vont dire que la chasse ça
sert aux prélèvements hockey dans le
canton de genève depuis 1970 il ya plus
de chasse et il ya eu aucun souci avec
les animaux n'y a pas de débordements
donc ça c'est pour la chasse il faut
vardon je peux finir merci
donc ça c'est que pour la chasse
maintenant je vais parler de la chasse à
courre la chasse à courre c'est un pour
cent de la chasse nationale donc on
parle même pas de prélèvement sepa du
prélèvement c'est pour se faire plaisir
des gens qui ont de l'argent vont aller
vont choisir un seul animal et ils vont
leur courir après pendant toute la
journée et au bout d'un moment on sait
bien en fait tous du footing ici autour
de la table quand on n'en peut plus on
n'en peut plus l'animal va s'arrêter et
là il va être accueilli par des gens par
des chiens qui m'ont qui vont le bouffer
de dand sous l'animal va se coucher et
là vous allez venir fièrement vous allez
poser un petit billet et vous allez
l'égorger avant de le regarder encore
une dernière fois je suis désolé moi
c'est quelque chose qui me touche
beaucoup
je suis fille de petite fille de deux
chasseurs et mon grand père c'était la
personne que j'aimais le plus au monde
et à chaque fois qu'ils partaient à
l'achat je lui demandais de pâtir et
pour moi parfois il le faisait parfois
il le faisait pas mais je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui en 2021 en plus où vous
êtes un jeune je n'ose même pas vous
regarder je suis désolé ça mais je
trouve que les jeunes puissent encore
soutenir ça moi ça me ça me dégoûte
il ya plein de gens qui sont dans les
dates delfina je le vois sur les réseaux
sociaux qui sont en pleurs qui s'envola
après avoir vu les images ça et delphine
votre témoignage chili un service en
fait juste pour revenir sur le combat
incroyable témoignage de ta sais pas si
je peux me permettre de relier plus sur
l'histoire du concours de genève
effectivement la chasse gardée dans ce
contentieux ça on va rentrer dans les
détails la c